hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech
career and life first of all i've got
new merch which i'm super excited about
because it's been a while so make sure
to check out the products in the merch
shelf down below
or in the store link in the description
box so as a lot of you know i worked as
an ios developer in silicon valley for
six years
and over the course of the last two to
three years of my channel i've talked a
lot about why i
love ios development and while i don't
necessarily regret this career path that
i took like it afforded me a lot of
great opportunities and i'm super
grateful for them and i do enjoy making
ios apps i also think it's important to
talk about
the cons because after like two or three
years of like hyping up bios development
i feel like it's time for me to like
talk about why i don't like it as well
because nothing is ever perfect
you know there's no perfect technology
or perfect career
so i just wanted to shed some light on
that side if you're watching this video
then maybe you're considering a career
in ios development or you're just kind
of canvassing
and seeing what's out there and you want
to learn the pros and cons of everything
unfortunately i personally can't give a
lot of pros and cons for all the other
fields because ios development is all i
ever know but i hope this helps
regardless
or maybe you're here just because you're
curious which is also super duper
welcome
thanks for watching and i hope you
subscribe and before we dive in i wanted
to say thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring today's video
if you're looking to expand your skill
set and learn something new
brilliant is the place to go brilliant
is a problem-solving based website and
app with a hands-on approach with over
60 interactive courses
in math science and computer science
their courses are all interactive which
makes it super easy to understand
stem topics like if you need to brush up
on your algorithms they've got a great
algorithms fundamentals course
or maybe you're taking a calculus class
right now but maybe you don't quite
understand the material from class then
they've also got a calculus in a
nutshell course
there's no tests or grades and you can
learn things at your own pace which
makes learning all this
so much more fun so make sure to go to
brilliant.org
hello myuco and start your journey today
only the first 200 subscribers will get
off the annual premium subscription so
make sure to check it out thank you
again to brilliant for sponsoring and
let's get back to the video
so the first point is that not every
company needs an app
if you think about all the platforms and
services and websites out there
a lot of them need like a website but
not every single one of them need an ios
and
android app and so as a result choosing
ios development as a career path meant
that kind of my
choices were limited in where i could
work granted in 2020 and the 2010s most
people
wanted to make an app for their product
anyways and so it wasn't so limiting but
if you look at the number of jobs in web
development for example
compared to ios development the sizes
are completely different
at the same time some products are
better suited for ios apps versus
websites as well so
it kind of goes both ways but i do think
that it's more universal for
companies to want websites before making
an app
next is that not every company needs a
lot of ios developers
kind of relating to the previous point
even if a company has an ios app
they don't necessarily want to always
invest a lot in mobile
and that's because the use case doesn't
make sense or they haven't
found one that does i started ios
development in 2014
and throughout the whole six years it's
also just been a struggle to convince
companies to just like
invest in higher ios developers too
there's always this debate
of like mobile first web first like
which one goes first if you had to
prioritize something
and oftentimes mobile loses out so
honestly i've spent a fair amount of
time convincing leaders product leaders
that mobile is worth investing in even
though i'm an engineer
but how else am i going to have things
to work on if
i don't convince people that it's an
important thing to work on it's
definitely getting better over time
though
more and more companies are like yeah no
duh we need an app for this
or you know they go mobile first even
just from the get-go but
it's something to keep in mind i think
next on the list for why i don't like
ios development and which is actually
probably like my biggest
con is that it's really expensive to be
an ios developer for those of you who
don't know
you have to develop ios apps and mac
apps on
a mac like you can't do it on linux or
windows or anything
which then means that in order to create
ios apps you have to have a macbook
and there's a lot of mac products out
there with varying price points but
i do feel like you need at least a
macbook pro you can run xcode on any mac
but if you run it on something like a
macbook air
it's just gonna be really smooth
i think like a 13-inch macbook pro has
like the minimum specs
of processing power in order to run
everything i mean also like xcode takes
like almost 20 gigs of space on your
computer so it's just like
it just rules out a lot of people if
macs are that expensive and that's
what you need as an entry into this
field so yeah the financial burden is
real so it literally rules out so many
people from becoming ios developers to
begin with because
not everyone can afford a mac this is
exactly why things like web development
catch on much faster because
anybody with any machine from anywhere
no matter their financial situation can
start coding
and apple consciously chooses their
price points like this and so until they
introduce like a two to three hundred
dollar or even five hundred dollar mac
line
yeah it's just gonna be extremely
exclusive so yeah that's something that
i really
don't like about ios development the
next thing is that xcode
is kind of hard to work with xcode for
those of you who don't know is the
official ide
for ios development made by apple and so
it's great because it's integrated
at every level like apple makes a
programming language the machines the
phones the ide
the frameworks and everything but it's
just it just doesn't work for me
sometimes
there's actually a lot of jokes in the
ios development community about like
how to coax xcode to do what you want it
to and
compared to some of the third-party
tools out there it is still the best but
it doesn't make it any easier to work
with sometimes because ios development
necessitates a compilation process
compile times can be super duper long
depending on the machine that you have
and it also gives like really cryptic
like hard to understand error messages
sometimes
and you often just have to clear the
cache and you have to like restart your
computer and whatnot so it's just like
it's just a part of ios development and
i wish it worked
a little bit easier but no development
tool is perfect so i guess that's just
what we got nonetheless it still made my
list for why i don't like ios
development so
ios development is kind of a niche
technology so i think it's actually
harder to translate to other
technologies that are out there
like my impression of web developers and
other developers that it's really easy
or fairly easy for them to pick up other
kinds of technologies and programming
languages
but because ios development is a closed
ecosystem and things do change but not
super drastically
it's just harder to like do like a
career change and hop across
to become a front-end developer for
instance so if you choose your vote as
an ios developer you can't kind of like
choose and hop between different things
but i mean ios is still niche though and
i say this because the patterns used in
ios and swift
are historically very but yeah it just
becomes harder and harder if you like to
pick up other things
but yeah it's still i mean it's just
still niche next on the list which is i
know a really big pain that
all ios developers share is that you
can't deploy
things whenever you want unlike web
development where you can deploy like
thousands of things a day and you can
deploy whenever you want at any hour of
the day
that's not the case for ios development
and that's because we have something
called an app store review process
apple put this in to ensure a level of
quality and safety
for all the apps that they have on the
app store for its users
which is great you know i think that's a
good thing it means that you can't
like download a virus if you download an
app from the app store but for
developers it means that you have to go
through a review process with apple
every single time you want to make an
update to your app
a really brief overview is that you
submit a binary to apple
they review it in about a day or two and
then they may
accept or reject it and then if it's
accepted that you can publish it but if
it's rejected you have to do a lot of
back and forth and try to fix the issue
and you have to adhere to all the app
store review guidelines
so yeah the fact that you have to like
wait a day for apple to get to your app
alone just
makes that whole process a lot longer
and so you have to kind of plan your
releases
and it also means that if you put out a
production bug out there then oh boy
it's going to be out there for
you know at least half a day so yeah you
just have to be more careful
and lastly on the list and i don't
really know how to like convey this but
i thought
i should say it is that like ios
development is like a little bit
campy which maybe all development is
kind of like this but i feel like ios
development in particular
is and i mean i think it's because it's
like apple you know a lot of people
revere
apple and sometimes in the ios
development community it's like they
revere apple so much that it feels like
a religion
or a cult and it's just like it's just
kind of weird it's like apple is this
god that changes and releases updates
and stuff and you're always just like oh
my god apple that's so amazing it's so
great
or you always criticize it for what it
didn't do and it's just like chill
yo it's just a company and some products
there's stuff like rivalry with android
and i'm just like dude like
who cares like everyone will use
whatever the phone they want and yes
maybe it matters in the business world
but like
no point in ios developers getting all
up in arms about who's better and who's
worse it's like
everything exists for a reason and
there's no better or worse so just like
leave it it's like not a big deal okay
so yeah because of this kind of like
culture of wireless development
and the financial hurdle that you have
to overcome
in order to be one it's not always the
most welcoming place
i mean there are a ton of great
resources ios developers ios tutorials
and teachers and websites and resources
that are super welcoming i can name a
few and i will leave them in the
description box down below
but yeah some pockets of it are just
like
sort of weird and i'm like why why you
gotta be like that
but yeah that could probably be said for
like all development and technologies
out there it's just
i mean it's a thing in the apple
community as well so yeah that's it i
hope you enjoyed this video and you got
to hear a little bit about
my personal opinion views early mine of
why i don't like ios development do i
still like it yes well i still keep
doing it
of course but yeah like i said i want to
make sure that you all get the full
picture that it's not this glimmering
perfect technology out there
and maybe you already knew that but just
wanted to talk from my own experience as
i do
on the rest of this channel so yeah make
sure to give this video a thumbs up and
please subscribe i would love to have
you as part of the family and show up in
your subscriber tab
so make sure to click that button down
below one last reminder of my new merch
please tag me on social media of you
sporting it and
i will see you next time bye